hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that happened last year on
leeches and it wasn't even Magnus
playing this game or rather it wasn't up
until this point that it wasn't Magnus
playing this game uh so it was a a
gentleman named Lucky River a leeches
Master lucky River and this was the
position on the board when he decided
that okay I've had it with this position
I've already blundered too much let's
just resign here but he didn't actually
click resign so Magnus took over his
place and he started playing here but it
was uh it was either a bullet game in a
tournament where they both went berserk
so they won both went down to 30 seconds
or it was uh actually a hyper bullet
game so uh could be I wrote those and
here they are playing against the
gentleman named GM BMW uh no idea who
that is that's why I'm honoring him by
wearing a hoodie and hope you guys are
as well now uh how could a position like
this happen already on move five well
one way to do it is and there's no clear
weight actually be certain of this but I
reconstructed with something like D4 D5
Ponte E3 with Ponte E5 now comes Pawn to
E4 or sorry Punta F4 and now Ponte e for
just blockading the center and now uh
and Knight to F3 which was a free move
so e captures on F3 uh White played
Queen to D2 and now F captures on G2 and
this is how such a position could happen
on the board and of course the player
that pre-moved um uh got off from the
table he did not want to finish this
game and Magnus took his place and
started playing this game but
interestingly when magnets took over he
was already down to 18 seconds on the
clock so he has 18 seconds for the
entire game and this is the position if
you're interested in the official uh
evaluation by by stockfish it is -5 for
black which means that black is
completely winning so okay Bishop
captures on G2 this is how Magnus
continues we have Queen to H4 with check
and now I believe the move that
inspired me the most in this game is
magnus's next move here Magnus just
played Queen to F2 his idea is that okay
he's down a piece but he wants to trade
queens and he's gonna improve the
position of his King and I'm pretty sure
that um everyone watching this video
including myself if faced with this
position would probably just move the
king king to F1 or King day two
and try and uh well keep the position
complicated keep the keep the Queens on
the board but not Magnus and we can all
learn something from this game as well
uh who amongst us has not blundered a
piece uh like this in the opening in in
a bulletin or or in a hyper bullet game
so okay Queen to F2 and now uh comes a
move that you most certainly did not
expect and that is Queen captures on H2
and black is also down extremely low on
time as the Magnus had some 18 seconds
when this game started his opponent had
some 26 seconds when the game started so
uh basically the the game is only
pre-move so Rook characters on H2 Knight
to F6 now and now Pawn the C4 but
interestingly even though Magnus is now
up material it will all even out in a
few moves so here at night the E4
attacking magnus's Queen Knight the C3
and now Knight captures on F2 so Magnus
gives back the queen and now we have a
fairly equal game where you know it's
just a game King characters and F2 and
Quant the C6 now defending on D5 but not
really as it's attacked twice so C
character C characters and now Magnus
plays Pawn to E4 he doesn't capture on
D5 like I said these are all pre-moves
Knight to A6 we have Knight captures on
D5 Knight to C7 and now Pawn to E5
opening up The Bishop's diagonal so King
to d8 defending the Knight and not
Knight captures and C7 King characters
and D5 Magnus could have captured on C7
uh you know before the king defended it
but uh he was very much focused on
pushing those pawns so here Bishop to C5
with the check uh Bishop to E3 and now
Bishop captures and King captures and
now because the King was an F2 because
you've made that early Queen trade now
Bishop to E3 was possible so you can see
how it all works out very nicely King to
D7 we have rooked the C1 now uh
preparing D6 and Rook to C7 we have King
to d8 and now Pawn to D6 with Bishop to
D7 now comes Rook the C7 going after the
B7 Pawn Rook the ba defending but now
Magnus just gobbles it up rook captures
some V7 Rook captures with Bishop
captures on B7 and now Ponte F6 striking
against the white strong Center here
Bishop to E4 and now F characters we
have F characters and now magnets will
of course try to get his King to D5 push
E6 and hopefully that will seal the deal
so H6 we have rooked the C2 now
uh trying to get the other Rook to the
seventh rank as well Bishop to E6 uh and
now we have King to D4 we have King to
D7 and now Rook the C7 check King 38 and
now Bishop to C6 with check now all of
these scores are covered by the opponent
by the bishop and something like Rook
captures an A7 Rook to A8 will be
Checkmate so here we have Rook the E8 uh
either uh something weird or trying to
create some sort of a stalemating trap
which is very unlikely as there are so
many uh pawn moves possible but okay
Magnus just grabs the pawn on A7 with
Bishop to D7 now and The Rook to A8 with
check with Bishop to C8 and finally now
there is a mating four we have Pawn to
D7 now attacking the bishop and the only
way to defend this is to move the king
so King the E7 but uh King to C7 was a
bit more resilient here Rook captures
and see it was played even though this
is mating one because of the Pawn on E5
but okay as all of the moves in this
game are pretty much Primo's Rook
captures and see it was played Rook to
d8 now comes Rook captures King captures
and now King to D5 so can black promote
his Pawn or will white be quicker to
Checkmate uh well the king is already on
D5 so I don't have to tell you what
happens so G5 Pawn to E6 with G4 King to
D6 Pawn to G3 as only pawnpo's a moves
are possible now and here Magnus just
played Ponte E7 and this was now
Checkmate so really incredible stuff by
Magnus taking over this position in in a
completely lost position with only 18
seconds on the clock and just um you
know just straight out winning and
against an opponent rated almost 2500
which is incredible in itself but like I
said okay as most of the game uh were
pretty much Primos the thing I found the
most interesting was that after this
check Magnus just offered a queen trade
so next time I blunder a piece like this
I'm just going gonna also offer a queen
trade and play a normal game so that
seems to be if it's good enough for the
world champion obviously that is the way
to go so maybe something you can take
from this game and also I definitely
suggest watching the actual footage of
this game will be the first link in the
description below uh you can see how
Magnus is just you know barely paying
attention to the game singing browsing
his phone and playing this game and then
just winning uh so pretty pretty
incredible stuff do check it out first
thing in the description below uh have
at it uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it a bit of a shorter
one I'm still recovering from my uh from
my illness that struck me uh you know
for the past two days like I said my
daughter brought something from the
Canada kindergarten and there's the the
nastiest stuff possible you can find
there
uh so yeah uh that's the game once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it if you
wonder please don't resign you know go
for the end game and if you're a strong
endgame player you should be able to win
uh if your opponent blunder is the queen
as well uh that that uh should also help
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
listerpan Joshua Baker Derek Alex
Williams Stephen Pryor and uh Chandra
subramanian for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day